this next email comes from Richard in
Seattle in a world where any name or
item can be essentially used as a
euphemism for a sex act well what a
Ralph Garman be and what would a Kevin
Smith be if someone were to do a Kevin
Smith what would that sex act be say oh
I gave her the old Kevin Smith last
night ass eating a CD that's relatively
simple why would they just say I ate her
ass last night why would they use the
Kevin Smith euphemism maybe they're
talking to their mother
what would a Ralph Garman be I thought
long and hard about this like this what
would it be it would be me and I blow
myself that would be roughly that's a
Ralph's no no no I would like to have a
woman sitting on my face and I am I am
enjoying the the fruits of her [ __ ]
yeah doing the show I was trying to be a
little more you know romantic about it I
got a woman sitting on my face and the
essence of love is there no respect so
she's sitting on your face but she takes
a bottle of Jack and she pours it on her
chest down between her breasts and it
just like a river of jack goes down her
body and enters my mouth as I'm
servicing her orally
so I get the best of both flavors
combined it's like like a Reese's Peanut
Butter Cup but for a grown-up its its
jack daniels and sweet sweet vagina
you got your [ __ ] in my jacket my [ __ ]
two great tastes that taste great
together I thought a Ralph Garman would
be you're getting you're givin you're
being given head and one of your
enormous balls can cuss as a woman
that's a burden I have to carry sir I
wish you wouldn't make fun of it
[Music]